the greatest living rock star is here in
our studio right now ozzy osbourne how
you doing hey aussie great to see you
sharon osborne of course is here his
lovely wife beautiful sexy wife good
morning and jack and kelly there kids
how you doing jack tired and kelly you
too you used to be excited to come in
here they're so jaded now you know what
happened
they used to come in here before they
were stars and had their own tv show
well no you don't listen i love the show
i mean what can i say the show is the
real life of ozzie and sharon and the
kids wow isn't it hard having the camera
on you all the time or did you like it
ozzy no some days at this moment some
days you you know that soon as you open
that bedroom door you're on and
sometimes sometimes it's going like not
now you know but ozzie went on for six
months do they pay you a lot of money
for this show to put up with six months
of of of uh taping in your show i can't
imagine they pay well she does all the
work
sharon what not a lot not a lot of money
it's kind of like a we did we
to be perfectly honest with you we had
no idea it was gonna take off the way it
did and robin initially it was only
going to be three weeks and suddenly
three weeks turned into months and it
just took on a life of its own and we
did it initially because i thought it
would be good to document our lives for
football yeah but you should have asked
for a bit more
cash right cranky yeah supposed to ask
for some cash
aussies around i'm busting my balls
doing gigs around 53.
[Laughter]
on the street corner now i was shocked
to see how much uh sharon has a role in
dressing you ozzy well you know what it
is howard you know
every every now and again i'll put the
right clothes on which is once every
blue moon but you say to sharon things
like hey sharon i don't like this jacket
and then she makes you wear it anyway
she
you're not wearing that you're not
walking down the street looking like a
can i just say no let me finish there's
a story
okay because aussie has no dress sense
first of all everything has to be black
which is fine why does everything have
to be black oh it's so clumsy no it
doesn't you could if i were if i wear a
white suit i'll guarantee a walk out
this studio and a bird crap on my
shoulder yeah but a black why the why
the hell would you want to wear a white
what are you doing
i'm just saying what are you a coke
dealer now no no
briefcase no what i'm just saying you
[ __ ]
your son i quit the family
hey i don't think you're allowed to quit
but josie what about i want to ask you
something seriously because i've known
you for a while now what about taking
matters into your own hands with like
what and saying i'm one of the biggest
rock stars in the world and he wouldn't
be here right now yeah but what about
taking matters and talking about his
dressing of his own clothes not asking
shout out to because he did listen
listen he did and you know what he did
one day this is just an example of one
day he comes to pick me up at my
hairdressers and i was up before him so
he gets up gets himself dressed he comes
in and he's wearing my black donna karen
nighty
well i don't know hold on hold on
it's a black t-shirt it's a nightie and
my hairdresser goes oh aussie looks like
boy george today he looked he had a
dress on but it was a nightie
overlapping
i'd say anything black goes in my
wardrobe
so the mates
did they do the cleaning yeah every i'll
get kelly's shirts so so the
relationship almost sometimes sharon has
to be the mother not just the wife even
to you ozzy right absolutely because i i
i can't make my mind whether i wanna
wear anything she goes put that and put
that and put that and she's i'm just
like another kid to her
you